where do you see Wikipedia
in 10 years 100 years and one thousand
years
right so 10 years
um I would say pretty much the same like
we're not gonna have We're Not Gonna
become Tick-Tock you know with
entertainment deals scroll by video
humor and blah blah blah uh an
encyclopedia I think in 10 years we
probably will have
um a lot more AI supporting tools like
I've talked about and probably your
search experience would be you can ask a
question and get the answer rather than
you know from our body of work so search
and Discovery a little bit improved
interface some of this all that uh I
always say one of the things that people
most people won't notice
um because already they don't notice it
is the growth of Wikipedia and the
languages of the developing world so
you probably don't speak Swahili so
you're probably not checking out that
Swahili Wikipedia is doing very well
um and it is doing very well and I think
that kind of growth is actually super
important it's super interesting but
most people won't notice that if we can
just learn that yeah if it could do you
think there's so much incredible
translation work is being done with with
AI with language models do you think
that can accelerate yeah uh Wikipedia so
you start with the basic draft of the
translation of Articles and then so so
what I
used to say is like machine translation
for many years wasn't much use to the
community because it just wasn't good
enough as it's gotten better it's tended
to be a lot better in what we might call
economically important languages that's
because the Corpus that they train on
and all of that so to translate from
English to Spanish if you've tried
Google translate recently Spanish to
English is what I would do it's pretty
good I think it's actually not bad it
used to be half a joke and then for a
while it was kind of like well you can
get the gist of something and now it's
like actually it's pretty good
however we've got a huge Spanish
Community who write in Native Spanish so
they're able to use it and they find it
useful but they are writing
but if you tried to do English to Zulu
um where there's not that much
investment like there's loads of reasons
to invest in English to Spanish because
they're both huge economically important
languages Zulu not so much so for those
smaller languages it was just still
terrible my understanding is it's
improved dramatically and also because
the new methods of training don't
uh necessarily involve
identical corpuses to try to match
things up but rather reading an
understanding with tokens and large
language models and then reading and
understanding and then you get a much
richer anyway apparently it's quite
improved so I think that now
it is quite possible that these smaller
language communities are going to say oh
well finally I can put something in
English and I can get out Zulu that I
can that I feel comfortable sharing with
my community because it's actually good
enough or I can edit it a bit here and
there so I think that's huge so I do
think that's going to happen a lot and
that's going to accelerate again what
will remain to most people an invisible
Trend but that's the growth in in all
these other languages
so then move on to 100 Years starting to
get scary well the only thing I'll say
about 100 years is like
we've built the Wikimedia Foundation
um and we run it in a quite cautious and
financially conservative and careful way
so every year we build our reserves
every year we put aside a little bit
more money we also have the endowment
fund which we just passed 100 million
that's a completely separate fund
um with a separate board so that it's
not just like a big fat bank account for
some future profligan CEO to blow
through that you know the foundation
will have to get the approval of a
second order board to be able to access
that money and that board can make other
grants through the community and things
like that
so the point of all that is I hope and
believe that we're building you know in
a financially stable way that we can
weather various storms along the way so
that hopefully we we're not we're not
taking the kind of risks and by the way
we're not taking too few risks either
that's always hard I think we'll the
Wikimedia foundation and Wikipedia will
exist in 100 years if anybody exists in
100 years you will be there do you think
the internet just looks unpredictably
different just the the web I do I do I
mean I think uh right now
uh this sort of enormous step forward
we've seen has become public in the last
year of the large language models
um really is something else right it's
really interesting and you and I have
both talked today about the flaws and
the limitations but still it's as
someone who's been around technology for
a long time I it's sort of that feeling
of the first time I saw a web browser
the first time I saw the iPhone like the
first time the internet was like really
usable on a phone and it's like wow
that's that's a step change difference
there's a few other you know maybe a
Google search Google search because I
remember Alta Vista was kind of cool for
a while then it just got more and more
useless because the algorithm wasn't
good and it's like oh Google Search now
like the internet works again yeah
um and so large language model it feels
like that to me like oh wow this is this
is something new and like really pretty
remarkable and it's going to have some
downsides like you know the the
negative use case I'm you know people in
the area who are experts they're they're
giving a lot of warnings that I don't
know enough to I'm not that worried but
I'm a pathological optimist
but I I do see some like really low
hanging fruit bad things that can happen
so my example is
um how about some highly customized spam
um where the the email that you receive
isn't just like
misspelled words and like trying to get
through filters but actually as a
targeted email to you that knows
Something About You by reading your
LinkedIn profile and writes a plausible
email that will get through the filters
and it's like suddenly oh that's that's
a new problem that's going to be
interesting
um is there uh just on the Wikipedia
editing side
does it make the job of the volunteer of
the editor more difficult if in a world
where larger and larger percentage of
the internet is written by an llm so one
of my predictions and we'll see you know
ask me again in five years how this
panned out is that
um
in a way this will strengthen the value
and importance of some traditional
Brands so if I see a a news story and
it's from The Wall Street Journal from
The New York Times from Fox News I know
what I'm getting and I trust it to
whatever extent I might have you know
trust or distrust on any of those
and if I see a brand new website that
looks plausible but I've never heard of
it and it could be machine generated
content that may be full of Errors I
think I'll be more cautious I think I'm
more interested and we can also talk
about this around
photographic evidence
so obviously there will be scandals
where major media organizations Get
Fooled by a fake photo however if I see
a photo of the reason was the the pope
wearing an expensive puffer jacket
I'm gonna go yeah that's amazing that a
fake like that could be generated but my
immediate thought is not I don't know so
the Pope's dipping into the money eh
um partly because this particular Pope
doesn't seem like he'd be the type
um my favorite is uh extensive pictures
of Joe Biden and Donald Trump uh hanging
out and having fun together
brilliant so I think I think
people will care about the provenance of
a photo and if if you show me a photo
and you say yeah this this photo is from
uh
uh Fox News even though I don't
necessarily think that's the highest but
I'm like well it's a news organization
and they're going to have journalism and
they're going to make sure the photo is
what it purports to be
uh that's very different from a photo
randomly circulating on Twitter whereas
I would say 15 years ago a photo
randomly circulating on Twitter in most
cases the the worst you could do and
this did happen is misrepresent the
battlefield so like oh here's a bunch of
injured children look what Israel's done
but actually it wasn't Israel it was
another case 10 years ago that has
happened that has always been around but
now we can have much more
specifically constructed plausible
looking photos that if I just see them
circulating on Twitter I'm going to go
just don't know not sure like I can make
that in five minutes so well I also hope
that
it's kind of like what you're writing
about in your book that we could also
have citizen journalists that have a
stable verifiable
uh trust that builds up yeah so it
doesn't have to be New York Times or
this organization that you could be in
an organization of one as long as it's
stable and Carries through time and it
builds up or no I I agree but the one
thing I've I've said in the past and
this this depends on who that person is
and what they're doing but it's like I
think my credibility my general
credibility in the world should be the
equal of a New York Times Reporter yeah
so if something happens and I witness it
and I Write About It people are gonna go
well Jimmy well said it that's just like
if a New York Times Reporter said it
like it I'm gonna tend to think he
didn't just make it up
truth is nothing interesting ever
happens around me I don't go to war
zones I don't go to big press
conferences I don't interview
Putin and zielinski right so just to an
extent yes whereas I do think for other
people those those traditional models of
credibility
um
are really really important and then
there there is this sort of Citizen
journalism I don't I don't know if you
think of what you do as journalism I
kind of think it is but yeah you do
interviews you do long-form interviews
and I think people you know like if you
come and you say right here's my tape
but you wouldn't hand out a tape like I
just gestured you as if I'm handing you
a cassette tape but if you put it into
your podcast here's my interview with
zielinski and people aren't going to go
yeah how do we know that could be a deep
fake like you could have faked that
because people are like well no like
you're a well-known podcaster and you do
interview interesting people and yeah
you like you wouldn't think that so that
your brand becomes really important
whereas if suddenly and I've seen this
already I've seen sort of video with
subtitles in English and apparently the
Ukrainian was the same and it was
zielinski saying something really
outrageous and I'm like yeah I don't
believe that like I don't think he said
that in a meeting with you know whatever
I think that's Russian propaganda or
probably just trolls yeah and then
building platforms and mechanisms of how
that trust can be verified whether you
know if something appears in a Wikipedia
page that means something if something
appears on um like say my Twitter
account that means something that mean
yes I this particular human have signed
off on it yeah and then and then you the
the the the the trust you have in this
particular human uh transfers to the
piece of content and then each hopefully
there's millions of people with
different metrics of trust yeah and then
you could see that there's a certain
kind of bias in the set of conversations
you're having so maybe okay I trust this
person have this kind of bias and I'll
go to this other person of this other
kind of buyers that I can integrate them
in this kind of ways just like you said
with Fox News and whatever sometimes
like they've all got their like where
they sit
um yeah